[Musique]
non
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes à saint pétersbourg dans
l'une des villes les plus renommés de la
russie moderne située au bord de la neva
son architecture somptueuse et ses
canaux qui la traversent la rendre très
célèbre pour sa beauté on l'appelle la
capitale du nord mais elle est surtout
nommé la venise du nord
[Musique]
saint pétersbourg est fondée en 1703 par
le premier rang peur russe pierre le
grand sur des terres froides et déserte
conquise sur les suédois lors de la
guerre du nord
l'empereur n'a pas lésiné sur l'argent
les hommes et les moyens pour édifier la
nouvelle capitale joyau de la russie
fenêtre sur l'europe grâce à son port
saint pétersbourg a joué pendant deux
siècles un rôle clé dans la vie
politique culturelle et sociale de l'
empire russe jusqu'à sa chute
[Musique]
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale la
ville a cruellement souffert a siégé
pendant presque 900 jours elle a connu
une terrible famine et des températures
glaciales c'est l'une des pages les plus
tragiques de l'histoire de la russie
moderne
[Musique]
mais la ville a réussi à conserver la
plus grande partie de son patrimoine
architectural et de nos jours saint
pétersbourg est l'une des principales
destinations touristiques du pays
notre invité d'aujourd'hui s'appelle
marc route booth et demi il a quitté
cette tunisie natale pour venir
s'installer à saint pétersbourg et
ouvrir sa propre boulangerie
par cette fraîche matinée des petits
croissants bien chaud me feront le plus
grand bien allons le rencontrer
bakou quand vas tu aujourd'hui ça va
très bien et c'est très bien ça y est je
suis arrivé sans peine je suis enfin
dans ta boule en soi est devenu vraiment
je suis très très content de te voir
merci à ces voix là alors tu peux vous
raconter un petit peu bienvenue
[Musique]
alors gras comme moi un petit peu
combien de côté ce que tu as ouvert ses
récents
ça fait cinq mois en fait quoi
la boulangerie fête du pain fait du
croissant depuis vu quelque chose comme
ça profitez de l'été en plus l'intérêt
alors un contre un petit peu quelle est
la particularité de ton de la
boulangerie en fait je suis le boulanger
et envers son propre projet en fait on
rocher se traiterait y en a pas
d'habitude c'est le businessman qui est
qui ouvre un boucher et après tu vois ça
sent un conte un boulot 6 heures
mais alors c'est toi qui sais toi qui
fait tout de a à z c'est vraiment ou
artisanal tout un acte zone alto
on fait je fais tout tout seul presque
j'ai les jambes bien sûr qui travaillent
avec moi parce que j'ai besoin de l'aide
tout ce que je peux pas faire tout par
contre début jusqu'à la fin je fais tout
je contrôle tout je suis toujours ici
dans ma projet est toujours je fais les
choses et chaque jour je sais de faire
mieux
c'est compliqué de faire un faire du
pain c'est compliqué mais j'aime
chassard ça j'adore ça j'adore cela vers
5 heures du matin venir faire du pass
sont bons
le partizan avec tes propres mains
j'adore ça
alors ça c'est ce que tu peux par le
soir dont je vois ici déjà des petits
croissants on dirait là qu'est ce que
c'est ça se prépare ça c'est la patte
pour du pain pâtes maïs avec des olives
d'accord après on va avoir du bon pain
avec des olives avec la patrie c'est là
c'est la patte d'une tartine
du pain traditionnel au levant en fait
on vient le matin à 5 heures du matin
quand on commence à 5 heures du matin on
commence à faire les pâtres en fait
n'est pas de croissants et tout ça ça
reste pour deux trois heures pour que la
pâte et le monde 16 ans tu sais ça et
après on va pour performer ses cuirs
monde sauf puisse vraiment une lueur
vous faites
là je vois aussi tué des bois il fait
chaud lundi dont
on sent bien la cuisson ce à ses dépens
que tu as tu appris tu as commencé à
préparer quand ça je le maintiens oui ce
matin en fait on a préparé ce pain c'est
le pain de seigle qui qui reste pas au
auffret la nuit la glace alpin que on
prépare aujourd'hui on lui puisse
aujourd'hui est-ce que la
russie s'y préparent les pâtisseries ou
le pin rouge comme ça une autre manière
que toi tu la prépare en fait oui les
grands
usine de grandes usines ils font
d'autres manières bien sûr il fait les
choses dont nous ont fait plus de levain
plus de du bon produit en fait bon
français pur produit français ou
international italien ou quelque chose
comme ça même on fait des choses russes
par exemple comme ce pas là mais on le
fait bien on le fait avec du levain pas
beaucoup de levure pas de levure et tout
ça mais par contre maintenant je peux
pas dire que je suis le seul par exemple
en russie on a beaucoup vraiment il ya
les gens qui font les vraiment vivons
qu'elle était et
c'est bien pour nous parce que quand il
ya des concours on commença
[Musique]
non c'est un magicien il fait cela avec
amour et cela se transmet quand on mord
dedans
[Musique]
lauriane je te présente ma famille l'ia
vous choisi voilà c'est vous travaillez
ensemble
en fait elle a travaillé toute sa vie
dans des banques et maintenant que j'ai
ouvert
langeree l'a commencée m'aider voilà
maintenant elle est vraiment à l'aise
c'est pas trop dur de travailler avec
lui ça va à vrai dire je m'attendais à
plus d'événements comment dire
beaucoup plus tragique veut dire ça
parce que je m'attendais qu'on se fâche
plus qu'on va avoir des disputes et les
jours parce que c'est quand même
travaillé avec son partenaire c'est pas
évident et du coup ça se passe beaucoup
mieux beaucoup mieux que je le croyais
et quel est ton rôle non non pas de la
boulangerie aussi tu fais les croissants
surtout pas
non je m'occupe de tout ce qui est
finance marketing comment es tu arrivé à
la boulangerie en fait préparer du pain
c'est ma mère on commence avec ma mère
quand j'étais vraiment très très petit
l'âge de 7 ans 8 ans elle me dit
aide-moi
fait ça fait comme ça elle fait comme ça
et j'ai du jeu dieu dieu contact avec
avec les pattes si je les touche et je
les joue j'ai joué avec eux c'est pour
ça ça reste après et je me suis dit non
j'ai pas d'autre choix j'aime ça je veux
ça je veux bien continuer à faire du
pain du pont creusot
marc godbout s'est mis est né en 1990 à
ghardimaou au nord ouest de la tunisie
son père à une société de vente de
volailles mais mahmoud s'oriente vers
l'hôtellerie et obtient en 2008 un
diplôme de gestion de restaurants et de
bars à l'école hôtelière de tabarka
entre 2008 et 2015 il alterne entre
l'entreprise familiale de son père et le
secteur hôtelier pendant la saison
touristique
c'est à cette période qu'il rencontre à
hammamet ioulia qu'il épouse en 2015
après leur mariage marque nous décident
de partir dans la patrie de sa femme et
commence par apprendre le russe à
l'université pédagogique de herde scène
à saint pétersbourg mais il se rend
compte que ces cours ne sont pas
suffisants pour apprendre rapidement la
langue et il commence à travailler comme
apprenti boulanger dans une chaîne
locale pour se perfectionner il décide
alors de suivre une première formation à
moscou puis en france à orléans où il
passe cinq mois en 2018 il revient à
saint pétersbourg où il est embauché par
la chaîne de pâtisseries de luxe garçons
en tant que chef boulanger
cette nouvelle fonction il gère une
équipe internationale et où il peut
créer de nouveaux produits ouvre de
nouveaux horizons en 2021 lorsqu'il voit
un local qui se libèrent juste à côté de
son domicile il décide de franchir le
pas et il crée sa propre boulangerie obs
qui ouvre en avril une semaine plus tard
mahmoud remporte le concours de la
meilleure baguette de saint pétersbourg
dont le jury est présidé par le consul
de france très vite up trouve sa
clientèle et yulia quitte son poste de
cadre bancaire pour venir rejoindre
l'équipe
alors ici nous sommes chez toi nous
sommes dans ta cuisine oui qu'est ce qui
se passe ici
bienvenue chez dans ma cuisine chez nous
dans notre appartement voilà ici on fait
on prépare tous que internationale comme
on dit tunisia russes les choses france
est vraiment il est n'est pas ta
italiens et les pizzas mais les pédales
et le borj le russe est vraiment
les verts faible borges voilà l'hiver
russe à son bord je ne sais pas mais
moi je remarque surtout une chose c'est
que on est à deux pattes à boulangerie
oui qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce que vous
avez joué vous avez d'abord choisi
l'appartement après la boulangerie ou
inversement quelques jeux whissell
appartement haut du bus et l'appartement
on vit ici ça fait saison comblent ici
c'est parce m'a dit ça tu vas tu vas
voir ta propre boulangerie c'est dans
cinq ans ou tu vas faire ton propre pain
d'antan projet jean michel ribes
[Musique]
je vois ici vous avez des magnifiques
cartes ah oui c'est le voyage c'est ça
vous voyez j'ai beaucoup oui on voyage
on ne laisse pas mal avant le petit
point sur wii on voyage toujours chaque
deux trois mois ont fait un voyage en
france en tunisie
beaucoup ses avants mais après les
pandémies moi ça fait deux ans que j'ai
pas eu le chance d'aller un rendu
inutile en fait pourquoi vous avez
choisi saint pétersbourg pourquoi tu es
choisi saint pétersbourg j'ai rencontré
hu jia je suis venu à saint petersbourg
en fait avant je savais pas ça veut dire
quoi la rue si tout ça directement j'ai
hâte d'aurel c'est vraiment j'adorais
j'aime et j'ai dit je me suis dit que je
vais vivre toute ma vie ici
[Musique]
saint pétersbourg est traversé par la
neva un fleuve court mais très large et
par un réseau de canaux et de petite
rivière qui représente plus de 10% de la
surface de la ville surnommée la venise
du nord elle a été bâtie sur un marécage
elle compte une quarantaine d'îles et
presque 350 points à l'intérieur de ses
limites avec marcondes nous avons décidé
de louer un bateau pour faire une
promenade fluviale et admirer la ville
sous un autre angle
[Musique]
matière beaucoup la ville j'adore la
ville
les ponts
voit l'eau dans la vie la coulée s'est
ici je peux vivre
je peux vivre je suis désolé mouchoirs
et la ville jacques prévert je préparais
sais pas ce que c'est
jose hot d'or
tu étais habitué facilement à saint
pétersbourg je veux dire par rapport à
la tunisie c'est un grand pas pas
rapidement premier à naître toutes
façons comme et un été très difficile
pour moi parce que
dont des mois j'avais avec
25 degrés en moins 25 degrés pendant des
mois la presse premières années après sa
mort et après on s'habitue s'habituer on
la prend l'habitude
j'aime c'est quelque chose de nouveau
c'est intéressant
est
ce que tu penses que le schéma influence
sur
le gens parce qu ici en hiver c'est
c'est noir qu'on a
20h02
en fait 4-4 5 heures de jour il quand il
fait jour elle après 20 heures
mons et c'est noir les gens restent
beaucoup à la maison fatigué pas envie
de rigoler bandits de parler beaucoup et
tout ça tout le monde juste à la maison
reste à la maison c'est difficile de
même temps de sourire et math aller
travailler est-ce que la mentalité des
tunisiens par rapport à la mentalité des
russes est-ce que ça a été compliqué
toit de passer d'une mentalité à l'autre
ou est ce que tu t'es habitué très
rapidement
vraiment
différents mais pour moi vraiment je me
suis j'ai directement l'habitude j'ai
commencéà pas à travailler j'ai commencé
à parler aux gens je m'attendais à autre
chose en fait on a reçu j'ai trouvé par
contre je trouvais que comment c'est
sympa les gens et vous tu vois tu sors
beaucoup avec les russes on sort avant
avant d'ouvrir notre boulangerie ou je
suis encore beaucoup le week end mais
après pas beaucoup de temps c'est pour
ça c'est même temps c'est eux qui vient
chez moi et devient mes clients voilà
oui c'est bien
[Musique]
est-ce que ça a été difficile pour toi
de d'ouvrir un commerce ici oui ce pas
facile au début vraiment c
il était avec les personnels surtout au
début voilà il y en a dans les vallées
chose les papiers les choses comme ça
les choses durent tout ce qui est
administratif c'est difficile j'aurais
dit que tout ça est née après
tout ce que je fais avec les mains les
crocs sont les pains l'aja doit il n'y a
pas de problème avec ça et trouver des
employés après les fins du mit en a
moins de gens il y en a moins je ne
comprends pas pourquoi mais en a moins
de gens vraiment c'est un peu difficile
de trouver les gens même temps
quelles sont les qualités nécessaires
qu'il faut avoir pour réussir
enrichit les qualités se doit de faire
le produit en qualité en fait c'est
l'expérience c'est le patient saussez
avec la vie que les gens il faut
travailler avec les gens savoir comment
comment parler avec eux tous travaux là
et les gens sont différents ce pour ça
faut comprendre comment comment il est
comme reconnaissons caractère quels sont
tes projets professionnels après un bon
look rihanna derrière un autre taux
longerait entre nantes et notre notre
oui j'espère beaucoup aux verts de des
autres boulangeries même à moscou
peut-être c'est ce que je te souhaite en
tout cas
[Musique]
pour
votre amitié ancienne date du jour où il
est arrivé à saint pétersbourg
il est arrivé
il a vite appris le russe il a commencé
à chercher sa voie ce n'est pas par
hasard s'il a maintenant cette
boulangerie qui marche assez bien
[Musique]
saint petersbourg en trois mots la neige
voudrait les nuits blanches et le succès
pour moi qu'est ce qui te plaît dans la
mentalité des russes
m'ont franchise il ya des choses ce
qu'ils pensent et disent pas ouvert
qu'est ce qui te déplaît
la première réaction quand quelqu'un ne
connaît pas et les toujours
faire existant et de la distance voilà
la distance au début est ce que tu
préfères les nuits blanches de saint
pétersbourg où les mille et une nuits
orientales les nuits blanches de simply
blanche se souhaite beaucoup de bonnes
choses merci beaucoup à toi je suis
vraiment ravi de votre deux temps si à
bientôt merci à bientôt revoir au revoir
me
[Musique]
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous avons passé un agréable moment avec
ma route bousselmi qui nous a invités
dans sa boulangerie et qui nous a fait
découvrir la ville de saint pétersbourg
de nouveaux lieux de nouvelles
personnalités toutes aussi intéressantes
vous attend je vous dis à très bientôt
sur arte france
[Musique]